I like to send people like cakes and
stuff like that I heard about this
coconut cake right and then one day I
received said coconut cake which said
happy Christmas Henry from Tom Cruise on
Christmas Eve there was just a knock on
my door I opened that there was no one
there and then I looked down and there
was just a pink box and it says yep it
has warmest wishes to you this holiday
season Tom Cruise it's the nicest cake
I've ever had
[Applause]
yeah it is well I'll call you when Mike
comes next what's that all about so you
must have shares in a bakery surely
and I thought this is yeah no there's no
way I'm eating that it's going to be
like made of healthy stuff cut it open
it is the most luxurious unhealthy cake
I love sugar but I can't eat it because
when I'm training you know I've got
doing all these these movies it's just
uh so I send it to everyone this is how
you look so good
you make everyone around you fat